你有沒有想過,既然巴菲特的持倉是公開的,那為什麼很多人不直接照抄呢?
這就好比學霸把答案公佈出來,你直接照抄不就好了嗎?
但現實結果是很少人會照抄,其實很多人是看不上巴菲特的收益率。
先看一下伯克希爾最近10年的年化收益率是13.7%,比標普高了1個百分點。
聽著不錯,但對很多人來說不夠。
很多人想要的是一年翻倍,三年財務自由,年化10%,這有些太莫解。
其實芒哥早就說過,沒有人願意慢慢變幅。
但真相是 能十年連續跑贏市場 不中斷 已經是鳳毛麟角了
不信你去看看各種基金 私募 能長年站上指數的有幾個
還有就是你抄的有可能是過期答案
巴菲特的持倉也一樣 他每個季度向SEC提交報告
但你看到的時候 已經是一兩個月之後的事了
但你知道 可能股價已經上漲了一些
而且他賣了你根本不知道 因為賣出是可以獨立即披露的
當然了 伯克希爾市倉比較多的股票變化不會那麼快
如今伯克希爾市值超過1萬億美元
現金等價物約3000多億美元
妥妥一艘航空母艦
起量太大
選股必然只能選萬億級別的巨無霸
小公司再優質
對整體收益也毫無影響
巴菲特也坦言
規模大是投資效率的最大阻礙
其實巴菲特曾經說過
如果給他100萬美元
他能賺到年化50%
其實巴菲特早年資金量小時
10年真實年化就達到過50%
這才是小資金應該參考的範本
巴菲特早年的投資體系
不靠長期持有巨頭
而是做煙地投資
它有三套核心打法
深挖被低估的公司
高具體性套利
取得公司控制權
重塑價值
靠著這套方法
30歲的巴菲特
就賺到了相當於如今的
1億人民幣的資產
你之前有沒有超過大佬的持倉呢
結果如何
評論區聊聊
想拆解巴菲特長年的具體打法
記得關注
我們下期聊